foreign
[Applause]
yeah I I sucked at it um you know
because it's interesting I remember way
back then when I was 16.
a couple weeks ago we um you need to
look like a baby you know you thank you
but you know you're gonna hit that curb
and I just I felt and the guy was just
like looking at me like you're gonna hit
the curve it's over and it's funny now
when I when I back up a parallel part my
wife is great at backing up she's like
backs and he's like Zoom I'm just like
I'm checking my kid's like Dad use the
screen a little ptsc on like that moment
yes so
um one of my favorite films in cinema
history
um is The Outsiders
it's a masterpiece
I didn't is it true that it was the
first book you read yes without without
my parents saying do your homework
um yeah I was not a great reader
um it's interesting because we have to
do that for our work God but I was uh
maybe I fell through the cracks in the
early grade school time of reading and
comprehension because I was reading and
daydreaming that I'd be on stage or in a
movie or Gene Kelly or or something like
that I grew I was very influenced by
those great old movies that mom had on
all the time when I was a kid but uh but
yeah The Outsiders was I read it in
seventh grade and
um I just so you know I connected to
those characters the story Essie Hinton
yeah the great SC Hinton the 16 she was
16 years old when she wrote this book
and then uh having the opportunity to be
in that movie that one holds a special
place I mean it just does thanks
I was reading about like um do you
remember the pamphlet they made for The
Outsiders yes I do I think I have one in
a bin in the basement somewhere so they
put out this cool pamphlet and each
character got their own box and it like
sort of accordion opened and closed and
they were on both sides and I used to
carry that with me everywhere I went
because I wanted to be in the group so
badly
um it's cool to be a greaser I mean it
is it just is yeah I was a greaser not a
sir for sure although Cherry Valance I
mean come on Diane Lane
um
but
how was the audition process with
Francis Ford Coppola it sounded like he
did something very unique not Orthodox
it's very unorthodox we all uh every
actor
um was in one big Sound Stage considered
like a room like this and all the actors
sitting around the perimeter and Francis
would call different actors to read
different roles and mix and match and so
you're you're already sweating because
you're in the room with one of the great
filmmakers yeah the storytellers in
cinema in American Cinema history yeah
everybody wants to be in this movie
because they love the book and yet
you're watching everyone's audition
saying watching the reaction of the
director it was really uh unnerving but
he you know he even talks about it I've
spoken to him about it in recent years
as well it was just really important to
him to mix and match and see the
chemistry because these these boys all
knew each other and had history together
so it wasn't just like okay here's my
two pages and you're out and so it was
very uh difficult but um worked out
worked out for me and it did because
you know which I've been reading it's so
beautiful and the story about your wife
that I loved so much was
um she was your girlfriend at the time
and is it true you took her to see the
movie I went to this sneak preview I'd
never seen the Karate Kid yet and I sat
in the back of the theater with my
girlfriend Phyllis who is now my wife of
35 years
um
and and I'm so I'm in the back of this
movie theater watching this movie a
month before it comes out and it was
just in concert everyone was it was a
love affair between the audience and
what was happening on this screen and
they were rooting and cheering and
crying and and jeering and whatever
emotion was going on they they
it felt like they knew this kid they
cared so much for this kid and there was
this moment where I was just like I'm
this kid this is crazy out of body and
it was just it's been that ever since
it's really quite incredible I know
there's such Goodwill with Larusso you
know
um John Appleton intercut your first
audition right with Pat morita's you can
see it on YouTube and I write about it
in the Memoir just that uh that
experience how
those words listen credit Robert Mark
came in for a wonderful script it all
starts on the page but the that
chemistry and the the attitude of those
characters were right there from the
first reading and then when I met Pat
who no one wanted for the they didn't
want Arnold from Happy Days in this
movie it was like no he's the wrong guy
this is the studio didn't want him the
producer didn't want him and avilson and
his casting director just put the tape
in and then he said okay let's get them
together Mia and patent mystery read and
it it was a chemistry it was like a
chemistry I opened the door Arnold was
nowhere to be found Miyagi was present
and and it was the most effortless easy
Soulful magic I've ever experienced and
still is going on today
I mean I
I'm quite shy I assume
on everyone's Behavior
but
auditioning is like the most vulnerable
weird it's like an awful process but
it's like there's no choice in the
matter have you ever had a nightmare
audition story well yes I I allude to
very often in success the the right
actor gets the right part yeah yeah
because I'll get that hey did you ever
audition for Back to the Future we
didn't I hear that you were for Ferris
Buell and I'm like you know there's
you're in the you're in the running
you're auditioning you're giving it your
your shot
um and then at the at the end of it when
I look at
Ferris Bueller is Matthew Broderick you
know Marty McFly and Michael J Fox's
Marty McFly you know
um and you go down this list so dare I
say maybe machio is Larusso you know
what I mean it's just the right
the right uh it just connection that way
but yeah
um certainly have had my share of
slipping and falling uh in front of it
but that's it you got to try to fall
forward right sure just I also don't
think your attitude is the right
attitude because you know we're all if
we've grown up in this industry and
we're lucky enough to maintain longevity
you just have to either adapt there's
two roads you adapt like you know
suffering from rejection or believing
everything happens for a reason and that
there's enough room for everybody that's
right
um and there is no Larusso without
machio that is for sure
I mean you just you've lived a beautiful
life and you've brought us along for the
ride in these iconic films and Cobra Kai
is you know how much I am obsessed with
it we talked about it the last time
you're on the show it is so hard to
reinvent and reimagine an iconic
property and evolutionize it the way
that they have and you guys have and I
just I'm so excited for your book I'm so
glad you're making all of our Lives
better and you know waxing on the Karate
Kid in Me is available now it is filled
with extraordinary stories from an
extraordinary person thank you
I'm so happy to see you thank you so
much for coming here it's great to be
here
[Music]